The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Hello and welcome.
As before, as you
might be expecting,
the big new news is, of
course-- well it's not new news.
The big news is
exam, tomorrow night.
This should be very
familiar stuff to you.
I apologize, a couple
people asked me right before
lecture about Fourier
because there was Fourier
on one of the previous exams.
There is no Fourier.
I should have probably
axed that problem.
So in my head I was trying
to be complete disclosure.
This is what the
exam looked like.
I didn't mean to send the false
message that there is Fourier.
There is no Fourier.
Next time we'll have
lots of opportunities
to ask Fourier questions,
so no Fourier this time.
On the other hand, yes, Bode,
Root Locus, that kind of stuff,
yes.
So, that kind of stuff
you should get on top of.
Questions or comments
about the exam?
I guess the one thing to
remember is it's in Walker.
It's not on the
third floor of 26.
Other than that, you should
be kind of in a good position
to know roughly what to expect.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When you say
two pages of notes,
do you mean two separate
8 and a half by 11 cards?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Yes.
So the idea is if you made
one 8 and a half by 11 front
and back for the last exam,
please just bring that.
Don't bother making a new one.
But you might want to make a
new one that contains stuff
that we've done since then.
That's the idea.
But we of course don't
care what you do.
Micro, you know, if you want
to bring-- so, no electronics.
But optical
magnification is fine.
If you want to bring a
little microscope, it's fine.
We don't mind.
If you can have an all optics,
no electronic, microfiche
reader, fine.
So the idea is just
to send the message
that you shouldn't be
spending a lot of time
leafing through 300 pages.
That's what we don't
want you to do.
AUDIENCE: Question.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Yes
AUDIENCE: Can we bring our
abacus, or is that not allowed?
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Can you bring your?
AUDIENCE: Abacus.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Abacuses are welcome.
In fact, I would love to
race somebody with an abacus.
I will take you on
with a slide rule.
[LAUGHTER]
Okay, so I learned with a slide
rule and the question was--
Well, no, you don't
want to know that.
I don't want to tell
you that, actually.
Okay, other questions, comments?
Abacuses, fine.
Non electronic devices.
So today is the final
lecture on feedback.
What we've done over the
course of the last week
and a half or so is looked
at a variety of applications.
Last time we looked
at how to perform--
how to improve
performance with feedback.
We looked at how you could
increase the bandwidth of an op
amp, increase the
speed of an op amp,
change a motor so that
its natural output, which
is a voltage
controlled velocity,
could be perturbed into a
voltage controlled position.
Today I want to just
do a few more examples.
Because what I want you to do
is leave this place thinking
feedback's really useful.
It's not just torture.
I mean it is torture.
We do torture you and you're
supposed to figure out
how it works quantitatively
and all that.
But it's not just torture.
It's actually very useful.
And that's what I
want you to take away.
The first application today
that I want to think about
is reducing unwanted
parameter variation.
So the idea that I
want you to think about
is what do you have in a power
amplifier of the type that you
would drive speakers--
of the type that you would
use to drive speakers.
That's a kind of a
complicated electronic device.
It's kind of hard
to make high power.
You end up having to
generate high power in order
to make a loud speaker that
fills this hall for example.
And if you were to
try to do something
bigger like a concert,
it's even harder.
And the problem with
those kinds of devices
is that they are active.
They generate signals
that are bigger
that generate more
power at their output
than there was
available at the input.
And we're very good
at such things.
Unfortunately, such things
are intrinsically non-linear.
So we actually take advantage
of non-linearities in materials
in order to do that.
The result though is
that at a high level
the thing's still non-linear.
And we can see some of that.
And not only non-linear,
but other things.
They can be
temperature dependent.
So if you were to make
a high power amplifier
it's very likely
that the performance
would depend on temperature.
Who cares, it's always
room temperature.
No, not inside the amplifier.
It may start out
at room temperature
every time you turn it on,
but within a few minutes
it's going to be much higher
than room temperature.
And if you didn't do
something about it,
the gain would change.
If you didn't do something
about it in your car,
it would track the
weather, which may be good.
Maybe it would
provide a distraction
and provide utility to winter.
But short of that
normally we don't
want the sound level that
comes out of a stereo system
to depend on temperature.
So how do you take a
device that intrinsically
depends on temperature?
Here I am imagining that I
have a power amplifier whose
gain can go between 8
and 12, say, depending
on what the temperature is.
How could you fix that
so that its behavior
was more consistent from day
to day, from hour to hour.
And of course, not too
surprisingly, the answer
is use feedback.
So how do you do that?
So you want to connect the
amplifier to the speaker.
After all, it's
inside the amplifier
that you have all
the transistors that
are able to drive the speaker.
So you don't want to
perturb that connection.
But what you can
do with feedback
is monitor what was the voltage
that actually got produced
and try to rig the feedback
system to coerce it
to the voltage you wish it were.
So the way you can do that is
to generate a feedback loop.
Precede the power amplifier
with a voltage amplifier
that does not necessarily
significantly increase
the power.
That makes that kind of an
amplifier somewhat easier
to make.
So imagine that
this power amplifier
has big chunky
transistors because it
has to generate amps in order
to make your speakers work.
This, by comparison, could be
a much less power hungry kind
of amplifier.
And it's easier to
make, and in particular
would be easy to make it
with a gain of 10 or 100
or 1,000 or 10,000.
We're very good at doing
that kind of stuff.
Then the idea of feedback
is to compare the signal
that you generated to the signal
that you might have desired.
So here's the signal
you generated.
Here is the signal you desired.
I'm comparing it
through a monitor
that's feeding back beta
times the output voltage.
The reason I do that
can be seen if you just
work through the math.
So if I just write the
closed loop transfer function
for x goes to y, the easy
way to think about that's
Black's formula,
of course, right?
So think about the forward
path, k times f naught divided
by 1 plus the loop gain.
So 1 plus the gain around
the loop is beta k f naught.
And now just think
about what would
happen if I coerced it so
that I made k the thing that's
under my control big.
If I make k big
enough, then I can
arrange so that beta k f naught,
independent of beta and k,
I can always choose k so
that the product is big
compared to the one.
If I do that, I
can ignore the one.
If I ignore the
one, the k's cancel,
the f naughts cancel, and
I'm left with whatever beta.
Beta didn't depend on f naught.
That's what I wanted.
It didn't even depend
on k, other than k
had to be big enough so
that the division worked.
So the result is that you
can make a stable gain
by incorporating an amplifier
with an unstable gain.
Unstable meaning that it
varies in time, not that it's
unstable in the sense that we
often use the word unstable.
I should avoid that.
The parameter of
the gain changes.
It changes between 8 and 12.
And I can illustrate that
with this kind of a picture.
If I plot the
variation at f naught.
I've showed a range
here from 0 to 20.
I'm imagining that in
a practical situation
it could vary between 8 and 12.
And then in red,
I'm showing the gain
that would result if
there were no feedback.
And as you can see that
over the range of 8 to 12,
the output gain, the
total gain of the system,
varies between 8 and
12, not surprisingly.
That's what it would
mean to have no feedback.
But if I crank in feedback, if
I set the k to 100 and feedback
ratio to 1/10, the 100 is
sufficient to make the one
negligible which means that
my overall gain is 1 over 10
determined only by the
feedback ratio, beta.
And so the result
is this line shows
the solution to that equation.
And you can see that
it's ruler straight
through the interesting region.
Does that makes sense?
So what I've been able
to do is use feedback
in order to control the
value of a parameter that
was otherwise variable,
or sensitive to something,
often temperature.
Is that all clear?
That kind of a thing--
Question?
I got rid of all the
variations, except beta.
What about variations in beta?
Right, the premise was
I couldn't control this,
it was going to vary
between 8 and 12.
But what if beta changes.
What if beta went
from 1/8th to 1/12th,
would that affect things?
AUDIENCE: So yeah,
so we could put
a feedback loop [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: You could
put in another feedback loop.
That doesn't sound like it's
going to converge quickly.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Typically we want to
be able to control beta anyway.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Right
AUDIENCE: There's
nothing users control.
DENNIS FREEMAN: That's right,
we'd want to control it.
Is there any reason we--
but that's what we wanted
to do with f naught too.
We wanted to control that.
We'd like that to be 10.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It will depend on
how that beta would change.
Changes, say, from
1/8th to 1/12th,
probably nothing to worry about.
If it changes from
1/8th to 1 over 8,000,
then you may want to think
about what k and f are.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So what
do you think will happen?
Do you think it will
vary a lot or a little
compared to 8 to 12?
AUDIENCE: Probably
not that much.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Why?
AUDIENCE: Because
the k is already--
1/8th and 1/12th is not
really much of a difference
in terms of--
DENNIS FREEMAN: So why do I
think about beta differently
from the way I think
about f naught?
Is there a good reason
for that or is that just
wishful thinking, right?
Engineering by wishful thinking.
I wish I could get a beta
that was exactly right.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: For amplification,
beta needs to be less than 1
[INAUDIBLE] so [INAUDIBLE]
the resistor, it's not
going to have a very big
temperature [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Precisely.
So the problem is getting
gain in a stable and reliable
fashion, not in
getting attenuation.
We can control the value of a
resistor with great precision.
And so it's easy,
by comparison, it's
relatively easy to control the
gain of a resistor network,
and much harder to control the
gain of a transistor network.
Transistors have gain.
Gain is hard to make in a non
temperature dependent fashion.
Division by a resistor, it's
not hard to make a resistor.
I mean it's not trivial,
but it's not hard.
Even in the dark ages--
even in the dark ages, resistors
were made by winding wires,
and they were very
stable with temperature
or could be made to be very
stable with temperatures.
So one of the tricks in
feedback is that we usually--
so we move the--
we move the parameter dependence
out of the forward path
and into the feedback
path with the idea
that we're moving it
out of the part that
has active parts like
transistors and into the part
that we can build
with passive parts.
And we almost always
do feedback that way.
Not always, but almost always.
Another important point
is that this could
work at a very high speed.
As an illustration
of that I want
to think about what would be
inside of that f naught box.
Here's a very
simple idea of what
you could put in there that's
based on two power transistors.
This is not a course
in power transistors.
I am not going to give
you a very good model
for a transistor.
There's other courses that
do much better justice
to that topic.
But what I do want to
say is that the idea
would be that turning those
transistors on and off
represents a significant
source of distortion,
or potentially a
source of distortion.
So for example, the
simplest possible model
I could think about
would say that in order
to generate, in order to
push this voltage to a higher
number, what I want to do
is turn this transistor on
because this will
pull this voltage up
toward the positive rail.
So if the input is such
that I'd like this to go up
what I would like to have
happen is that this transistor
would come on and conduct
current this way, which would
suck this voltage up to there.
To do that, the voltage here
has to exceed the voltage there.
For a BJT, that's not the
only kind of transistor
I'm just illustrating one
particular kind of example.
For a bipolar
transistor of this type,
the way you would turn
that transistor on
would be to have
this voltage exceed
this voltage by at least some
threshold voltage, nominally
0.6 volts, which means that
the kind of relationship
between v out and v in that you
would get is illustrated here.
If the input voltage differed
from the output voltage
by less than plus or minus
the threshold voltage, then
nothing would happen because
neither transistor would be on.
If the input exceeded what
was desired for the output
by more than 0.6, the
transistor on the top
would start to come on, and you
would get roughly linear growth
in the output voltage in
relation to the input voltage.
Similarly with negative.
If you make the voltage at the
input sufficiently negative,
you can cause the
bottom transistor
to come on and suck the
voltage down toward minus 50.
But again, you have to
exceed the difference.
The difference has to exceed
something like the threshold
voltage, normally about
0.6 volts, which means then
that you get this piecewise
linear approximation
to the relation between the
input and the output voltage.
The problem with that is that
it distorts the waveform.
So if I imagine a
purely sinusoidal input,
what I get at the output then is
not a purely sinusoidal output.
And, in fact, that's
quite objectionable
for many purposes.
In particular, in
the example where
we're listening to a sound, if
we were to listen to this sound
it would sound very
different from the way
a sine wave would sound.
So the way I can do that
is, not surprisingly,
fix it with feedback.
Again imagine that this
is the complicated part.
v f naught, followed
by the speaker,
put some gain in front
of it, gain's cheap.
We can do that run
relatively well.
And put in feedback
so that I can directly
compare how is the speaker
voltage compare to the voltage
that I'd like to listen to.
The result then
is that, depending
on how big is the
gain, I can change
how big is this dead zone.
The zone of input voltages that
produce no change in output.
So if I turn up the gain, here
I am illustrating k equals one.
If I turn it up to k equals two
the dead zone gets smaller--
k equals four,
eight, 10, whatever.
So the idea is that
by adjusting the gain,
I control how much
feedback there is.
And I can control how
distorted the wave form looks.
And I can illustrate how
bad it is to not do that
by comparing an
original clip of music
to different values
of the feedback.
So what I'm going to do
is play this many clips,
some original--
the original that
came off the mp3.
Put it through the system
with no feedback, that
is to say there isn't a k here.
There's no feedback loop.
You just put v in a v out.
Then k of two, four, eight, 16,
and then back to the original.
And if you listen, you
should be able to hear
the effects of the distortion.
OK.
Ready?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You hear?
OK.
Everybody get to hear it?
So the point-- although the
acoustics in this room are
terrible--
but even somebody with
as old ears as mine, I
can hear a very big
difference even between k
equals 16 and the original if
I listen to it over headphones,
or if I listen to it in
a better environment.
So the point is that we're
very sensitive to it.
In fact, 16 isn't even close.
I mean, in a real
kind of an amplifier
you would use gains
of at least 1,000
in order to make it acceptable.
So the point is that
we can use feedback.
So the overall point
is to try to illustrate
the kinds of things we
can do with feedback.
Here what we're doing is making
a system that's intrinsically
non-linear more linear.
Questions?
Comments?
Left turn approaching.
So what I want to
close with then
is two more examples
that are much more fun.
They're examples of
the use of feedback
to stabilize unstable systems.
This is kind of connecting
back to the very first lecture
in this series that
Russ gave where
he did some very
complicated control
problems by doing feedback.
I'm going to do some
slightly simpler ones.
But they're hard
enough to be clear
that they were a hard
problem, and easy enough
that every one of you should
be able to write the equations
and figure out what
I'm about to do.
If you are interested to do
the more complicated things
like having owls
come in and swoop,
that's a research project.
So this is supposed to be in the
middle ground between research
and trivial, right?
So I'm going to do some examples
now of some unstable systems
to illustrate how you would
use feedback for stability.
First example, is
magnetic levitation.
You've probably heard
of magnetic levitation.
Magnetic levitation is hard.
We've talked about magnetic
levitation since the 70s
at least, perhaps the 60s.
It's hard because
magnetic systems tend
to be intrinsically unstable.
Not always, but
the easy ways you
can imagine using a
magnet to levitate things.
We'd all like to
make anti-grav right?
Anti-grav would be
a really good thing.
And it seems like you
ought to be able to do
that with a magnet, right?
So the idea is what I would
like to do is levitate
a mass with a magnet.
Anti-grav, right?
We've had that since
Star Trek, right?
It's time somebody built it.
But it's hard even though
we can make magnets.
Even though we can
make things that
seemed like they would do it.
It's hard because it's
intrinsically unstable.
This particular system
is intrinsically
unstable in the sense
that if the mass, let's
say that it was at
equilibrium by which I mean,
in the absence of
somebody touching it,
it would stay exactly
the way it is.
That's what I mean
by equilibrium.
Let's say it was
at equilibrium so
that the magnetic force I found
was just sufficient to hold up
the weight, Mg.
If I came over and
just very gently bumped
the mass up a little, what
would happen to the force?
Force will go up.
So you're supposed to remember
this from some subject
that you took before, right?
Yes, no, yes?
It started with an 8, yes?
So the idea is something
to do with if you
have a magnet of that type,
you generate magnetic fields.
You remember they're not
supposed to cross, right?
One of the rules is
they don't cross.
[LAUGHTER]
But the idea is that the
density of flux lines
decreases as you
leave the magnet,
and the force
that's generated has
something to do with the change
in the density of flux lines.
If you move an object
through a region
where the number of flux
lines doesn't change,
it takes no force.
If you move an object
into a region that
has fewer or more flux
lines, it requires force
to make that move.
That's the idea.
So, since the flux lines are
thinning as you move away,
if I push up it will generate--
I'm moving the mass
into a place where
there is a greater density of
flux lines, that will generate
force up on the mass.
That's bad, right?
I had the force exactly where
I needed it to be in order
to levitate the mass.
If the force goes
up, what happens?
It accelerates up.
Well, OK, so it
accelerates up, then what?
Well, it gets closer.
Then what?
It accelerates faster.
So, the problem is that
the position is unstable,
or we might say quasi stable.
So what we can do is
make a model of this
to try to understand how we
could fix it with feedback.
Imagine that I
represent the magnet
by a function that
maps for every value
of the position of the mass
why it generates a force, f m.
Then, because of the
shape of the field lines,
I'm expecting that
the force increases
on the right of the
curve and decreases
on the left of the curve.
If I'm sitting for y zero
at equilibrium what matters
is the difference between y
and the equilibrium place.
And the important
force is the difference
between the magnetic
force and Mg, the weight.
So I get a simple
relationship that
says that this force,
this vertical line, f,
should be m a.
F equals m a which
is m y double dot.
So having generated
that kind of a model
I can now imagine putting
that into a feedback system.
So now I put the model into the
feedback system and this junk
over here, this is f equals m a.
f gets multiplied by
one over m, that a.
a is y double dot.
Integrate it to get y dot.
Integrate it again to get y.
But y was the thing that
controlled the magnet
in the first place.
So I'm trying to cast magnetic
levitation into a frame
for understanding feedback.
So now if I want to
further simplify things
I can replace the magnet model,
at least for small deviations
in position, by a linear gain.
So I'm making a straight
line approximation
to this curvy line.
And then we have
something that we
analyze all the
time, simple feedback
system that has integrators,
gains, that kind of stuff.
It's surprisingly similar
to the mass spring dashpot.
Springs, by contrast to magnets,
springs levitate stably.
What happens if I
push-- so I'm suspending
a mass from a spring,
if I push up on the mass
how does the force
in the spring change?
Gets less.
That's what you want.
It's no longer sufficient
to hold the mass up,
so the mass falls.
Push up, the mass tries to fall.
Pull down on the mass,
it tries to pull up.
Spring levitates stably.
Magnet levitates unstably.
OK?
Almost the same system though.
Here's a way of thinking
about the magnetic levitation
like we just saw.
Here's an equivalent diagram
for the spring levitation.
Almost the same thing.
The critical thing is that
minus sign and that plus sign.
So what's the relationship
between the poles of the spring
and mass system and the poles
of the levitation system?
Look at your neighbor.
Say the word poles.
We say that a lot in this class.
How do the poles relate
in those two systems?
[AUDIENCE CHATTER]
OK, so draw the poles in
the air for the two systems.
How do they relate?
Excellent.
I saw one right answer.
Somebody else draw some--
I'm not sure if I
caught that one.
So how do the poles relate?
Come on, somebody
drawn it in the air.
I've got one right answer.
OK, your air drawings
are a little cryptic.
Here's a not so air drawing.
So here's a picture of what they
look like for a spring and mass
system.
And all you do is think about
the differential equation,
turn it into system
function, there's two poles,
factor the denominator,
you find that the two poles
are on the j omega axis.
j omega axis, that sounds bad.
Yeah, it is bad,
right? what happens
if they're on the j omega axis?
Oscillate.
If they're right on the j omega
axis, it oscillates forever.
That's exactly what
a mass spring dashpot
does if you have no damping.
OK, it's bad.
But it's not nearly as bad
as magnetic levitation.
Magnetic levitation, you get the
same distance from the origin,
but it's turned to plus
and minus something.
That one.
I like.
That one I don't like.
That one is unstable.
So the question is, how can
you make a magnetic levitation
system?
How do you make a
system that we use
a magnet to levitate a mass when
the physics are intrinsically
stable?
And the answer is--
feedback, of course, yes.
So the idea is that
here is our system that
was intrinsically unstable.
What we'd like to do is
somehow change the physics.
One of the ways we
can change the physics
is by modifying the current
that runs through the magnet.
If we changed the
current from i naught
to 1.1 times i naught,
then the forces
everywhere would be bigger.
We could use that idea to
introduce a second feedback
path.
There is the intrinsic
one that comes just
from the physical layout.
But I'm going to add a path that
senses the position of the mass
and feeds back a
change in current.
And if I do this carefully,
I can arrange this path,
the intrinsic one has positive
feedback that was bad,
but the one I add has negative
feedback, which is good.
Then the overall system looks
more like this where I've got
k, which I cannot
affect, that's physics.
But I've got k two
that I can affect.
And what's showed
here is a root locus.
As I change k two, what
happens to the poles?
And what you can see is since
they were equally disposed
on the two sides of the j omega
axis, as I turned up the gain--
you can do this just by doing--
factor the polynomial.
Right?
So I factored this to
generate this plot.
As you increase k two the
poles go toward each other
and then they split,
and they become complex.
Complex is good.
But this still has the
problem that the mass spring
dashpot had if it
didn't have any damping.
So it's better because
at least it's stable--
Oh well no it's not stable.
It's marginally stable.
It's now oscillatory.
It no longer has eigenfunctions
that grow with time.
The problem is they
don't shrink either.
They state constant
in amplitude.
But you can fix that,
and what I'll do now
is show a demo that was done by
Professor James Roberge where
the idea was you don't have
to just put the extra gain in.
What Jim did was put a zero too.
So these are the intrinsic poles
from the magnetic levitation.
This is a zero introduced
by electronics.
The zero has the effect
of bending the poles,
the closed loop poles
around, so that you can then
make it stable.
So [INAUDIBLE].
So here's Jim's device.
And the goal now
is to smash fingers
because it will try to levitate.
So this is a hunky magnet.
This is a hunky power supply.
And that is-- well this
is the power supply.
This generates DC voltage that
drives the amplifier that's
inside this box.
So the idea then is we
have this metal ball.
So we have this metal ball,
and it's kind of heavy, right?
You know, it's not
like some nuclear--
it's not uranium or
anything, but it's heavy.
And the idea is going to
be to use the hunky magnet.
Let's see, can we see?
Oh yeah, OK, so you
can see it up there.
So you can see
maybe that here is
the pole of the magnet,
which is right there.
So there is the pole, a
different kind of pole.
[LAUGHTER]
Not to be confused.
So that's the iron
core of the magnet.
And you can see
the turns up here.
And here you can see some light.
So what's going on here
is a source of light
is being aimed
toward a photo sensor
so that when the mass, the
ball, is levitating at exactly
the right place, there's a
signal that gets fed back
into the control box to do the
thing that I have illustrated
here.
OK, everybody knows
what's going on?
I'll smash my
fingers now and then
ask Lorenzo to do it correctly.
So what I'm going
to do now is try
to move the mass into
the air so it levitates.
so successful would be
you're watching up there
and there's going to be a ball
up here, and it will levitate.
Unsuccessful is I'll
have a black and white--
a black and blue fingernail.
So, let's see--
Lorenzo is laughing at me.
[LAUGHTER]
LORENZO: See your hand can move.
OK.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Nope,
that's not going to work.
LORENZO: You don't
have a way to move?
DENNIS FREEMAN: Yes.
LORENZO: Yes.
DENNIS FREEMAN: OK,
this will work better.
If I get coached
enough, I can do things.
LORENZO: Yeah!
Oh!
DENNIS FREEMAN: Almost!
[LAUGHTER]
OK, it was close.
No, no, no.
Failing once is fine.
Failing twice, no
that's not acceptable.
Wonderful.
OK, so that's magnetic
levitation made possible
by feedback.
That's the point, OK?
Everybody sort of
knows what's going on?
OK, so to redeem myself
we'll leave the demo set up
and after lecture
you can come down
and you can do it and
smash your fingers.
Questions, comments,
everybody knows the point?
So we'll leave it there just
for entertainment value.
LORENZO: It will get hot.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Oh, OK.
OK.
You don't want to
burn it up, huh?
Good.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So the next demo is the
famous inverted pendulum.
The idea is that if
you have a pendulum--
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Was k
oscillating also?
With the--
DENNIS FREEMAN: Correct.
Correct.
So, that's a good question.
OK, so did I screw up?
Not a chance, right?
Or for those of
you who know me--
what would you conclude
if it was oscillating
and I told you I
thought I built this?
I screw up the circuit.
I screwed up the
root locus diagram.
Everything's hunky dory,
and I did everything right.
None of the above.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Positions.
OK, so flaky hardware.
Universal solution right?
Could be.
There's a different
explanation, which is possible,
but your explanation
may be right.
What's another explanation
besides flaky hardware?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
complex poles.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Complex poles,
but didn't I stabilize them?
Leading question.
Didn't I stabilize them?
The answer is, didn't
I stabilize them?
Yes?
No?
Completely cryptic he is.
AUDIENCE: I mean they can
still have complex values.
DENNIS FREEMAN: They
could have complex-- how?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
don't know where they are.
DENNIS FREEMAN: And
so what depends--
what determines where they are?
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
DENNIS FREEMAN: What
determines what they are?
AUDIENCE: Whatever your--
whatever you set [INAUDIBLE]
k or gain.
DENNIS FREEMAN: k
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Exactly.
So I get to control
this k two thing.
And as I change k two,
the poles start out here,
they go toward each other.
So if k equals
zero they're here.
As k gets bigger they do this.
So it's possible that
they're just simply here.
Right?
The poles could
still be complex.
If that were true, you would
expect the oscillations
to die with time.
Right?
If the oscillations
didn't die with time,
it's still possible-- well,
if they don't die with time,
then I guess I
screwed something up.
Right?
Because even if
they just come here,
they're oscillating but they're
on the left part of the axis so
they should decay eventually.
So I guess to the
extent that they
didn't die eventually, something
screwed up with the analysis,
the hardware is
screwed up, something.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So is root
locus due to k or k two.
DENNIS FREEMAN: k two.
You can draw a root
locus for anything.
You can change any
parameter and sketch
the locus of points
where the roots move to,
hence the name, root locus.
This is for k two.
So z zero was fixed here,
held constant, and k two
was modified to
trace out that loop.
The next example is pendulum.
So just like spring
mass system, spring
levitated mass in
a stable fashion,
although perhaps oscillatory.
So this pendulum is also
stable in that same sense.
Might be oscillatory, but
it will eventually stop.
Of course pendula are
not very interesting.
What's interesting
is inverted pendula
where the rule is
what I have to do
is stabilize this by moving
my hand to compensate.
So let's say that it
starts to move this way.
I've got positive feedback
that tends to make it continue.
So if I started at equilibrium,
by which I mean a state
that would persist
if nothing changed.
So if I started at
equilibrium, but then
perturbed it by
breathing, or whatever,
or by just not being quite
at equilibrium, it'll move
and then I have to do
something to compensate,
otherwise it'll fall down.
And there are people who
can do this better than me.
But we don't need to have--
I don't need to be coordinated.
I can build a system
that's coordinated instead.
That's the value of feedback.
So I can be uncoordinated.
Before I do that--
no, let's do this first.
So, here is a
mechanical system that
uses feedback to stabilize--
I'm not going to
read anything right?
So here is a pendulum,
an inverted pendulum.
There's some stuff down here.
There's no active parts.
This stuff is a
potentiometer, just
like the potentiometer
on the back of the motor
that I demonstrated.
And what it's doing
is providing a signal
to electronics that will let
the electronics say, oh, it's
moving this way.
Now, the cart is on
wheels, and the wheels
are connected to a hunky motor.
If the weight starts
to move this way
what should the hunky motor do?
Push the cart that way.
So that's the idea.
So I've got a one
dimensional inverted pendulum
and I'm explicitly modeling the
idea that I'm-- that the base
is moving.
So over here is an
outline of the way you
think about that-- the way
you can think about that.
I got the car and
it's in a not invert--
the car as supporting
a pendulum.
The pendulum is in
a non inertial frame
because the mass--
let's say that I'm approximating
the pendulum as having
all of its mass at the end.
That's an approximation,
but it's not
a critical approximation.
So I can imagine now that I've
got an input variable, which
is x, the position of the car.
And I've got a
feedback signal that's
trying to feedback
to me how much is
theta, the angle that
the pendulum is making.
And so what I want
you to do now--
so if you just write
801 kinds of stuff
you can imagine that the if--
So, first off, you've got--
instead of f equals m a, you
have torque equals i omega.
Everybody's happy about
torque equals i omega, right?
And, if I want to be in
a non inertial frame,
one way to account for the
fact that the car is moving
is to compute torques about
the point of insertion.
Then I can represent the
effect of the moving car
as a pseudo force on the mass.
That pseudo force
is in proportion
to the acceleration of the car.
And I've got the weight of
the inverted pendulum trying
to pull it in the
other direction.
And if you think
about all this stuff
you get this kind
of an equation.
So this is i omega dot, i
omega dot equals, and then
I have to worry about torques.
There's the torque
that's due to the weight,
and there's the torque that's
due to the cart movement.
so the question then is, what
are the poles of this system?
We want to think about all of
these kinds of systems using
003, because it's
such a powerful thing.
So what are the poles of
the inverted pendulum?
Look at your neighbor.
Say the word pole.
[AUDIENCE CHATTER]
Where do the poles--
Bump the car.
[AUDIENCE CHATTER]
OK, so where's the poles?
Sketch them in the air.
No that didn't work at all.
So to think about
where are the poles you
can think of-- the
hard part is just
the sinusoidal
trigonometric non-linearity,
so what do I do with that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Throw
it away, absolutely.
So I'll assume that
the sine of theta is--
AUDIENCE: Theta.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Theta.
And the cos of theta is?
AUDIENCE: One.
DENNIS FREEMAN: One.
For small angular deflections,
just make a small angle
approximation.
When you do that it
comes out surprisingly
to look just like the
levitated mass problem.
You get real poles on each
side of the j omega axis.
So in fact, you have to do a
similar kind of stability thing
to make this work.
And so that's what
we'll demonstrate now.
So the idea is going to
be to turn on electronics
to stabilize the inverted
pendulum so that I don't
need to do it with my hand.
LORENZO: I'm not sure it's going
to work, because I [INAUDIBLE]
the cord.
So if [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: It always works.
He does it really well.
LORENZO: That works.
DENNIS FREEMAN: So it's a
little more stable than me,
but not much.
I mean, I'm pretty good, right?
[LAUGHTER]
DENNIS FREEMAN: I can
keep it going too, right?
Well, sort of.
So is it any better than I am?
So can you share that it's
better or worse than me.
LORENZO: It's better than you.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
It's better than me?
Prove it.
Go ahead.
LORENZO: The way [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: So
you ought to do this.
So this guy.
So can somebody
think of something
that's different about this
from the magnetic levitation
problem?
AUDIENCE: Like
right now it looks
like it's going to converge.
DENNIS FREEMAN: But it's
doing a really good thing.
It's converging around here.
What would happen if
I was doing my thing
and it started to fall this
way, so I started to follow it.
That's actually
very complicated.
So there's actually another
feedback loop inside here
that's trying to make
it stay in the center.
So if I tried to
pull that one out.
Wap!
OK, so there's many feedback
loops going on here.
There's the one
that you can see.
But then there's also
a slow feedback loop
trying to keep the whole thing
oscillating in the center.
Everybody follow that?
So there's the primary
feedback loop, which
is very analogous to that guy.
But then there's a slow feedback
loop saying wait a minute,
you're spending too
much time to the left.
I'm going to move it a
little bit in the wrong way
so that you migrate
toward the right.
But the result of
that is very stable.
How stable?
LORENZO: We'll find out.
DENNIS FREEMAN: I didn't put
a battery on the top of mine.
[LAUGHTER]
I could have!
Well, I could've put it there.
So now we put the--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I think
someone should sell this.
DENNIS FREEMAN: A volunteer!
[LAUGHTER]
Everybody in favor?
It's overwhelming.
OK.
So that's all for today.
The idea is that
we can use feedback
to do a whole bunch of things.
And maybe even more tomorrow.
Oh well now that's just a joke.
See you tomorrow at the exam.
No recitation.
We'll stick around for
two or three minutes.
You can look at these
more if you want to.